we're acting dhs secretary chadwolf
welcome chad so the u.s gover or the uh
general senior generals basically said
yeah dhs has
says they're going to need some help
from the pentagon are they going to get
that help
well they're they likely are in one
manner or another what dhs is doing now
is what we call a request for assistance
or an rfa and so they're putting down on
paper
all the different duties and
responsibilities that they may need from
the department of defense so i think
this is interesting right they they
still to this day refuse to call this a
crisis refuse to admit what it is which
is really the worst uh the worst numbers
that we have ever seen in a generation
uh really since we started keeping
numbers uh they'll ask dod department of
defense for their help but they won't
talk about this to the american public
so i think that's very interesting
yeah it's a total deception but the
people who aren't deceived by this are
those living on the border who are
probably you know gripping for um more
chaos a more crime
um
more uh strain on the social services
that they have in their communities that
they they can't even service their own
people now their own american citizens i
want to move to another topic it's
really i think that go ahead finish that
and then we'll go i i think that's right
i think it's important for for folks to
remember that you know we're on track
this fiscal year which we're only about
five or six months into it to actually
eclipse last fiscal year which was the
highest on record ever and so i think
that's what it tells people that there's
no strategy at the border there's no
plan in place they tore down a number of
successful initiatives uh during the
trump administration but they didn't
replace them with anything and so the
only thing that's really keeping them
their head above water is this title 42
which we hear is going away as well and
so i think once that occurs the crisis
that we are seeing uh you know for the
past 12 to 13 months
becomes catastrophic uh when they are
unable to remove individuals and you see
a larger number of individuals showing
up to cross that border
yeah and now we're hearing about russian
agents in mexico
another troubling situation because if
the border border's open what does that
mean for us
mexico by the way has been neutral on
ukraine um and and russia conflict but
mexico now says that they're downplaying
let me just tell you this quote and then
get your thoughts on this um this is uh
from mexico's president he says we don't
have information on this mexico is a
free and independent sovereign country
we're not going to moscow to spa a spy
on anybody nor to beijin beijing nor to
washington which doesn't really answer
the question
chad about are there russian agents
working in mexico and does mexico know
about it so tell me what you think about
this
well i think what the world knows is
that if you want to cross into the
united states and you want to do it
illegally it's wide open you can do it
along the southern border and so that's
why border patrol picks up over 120
different nationalities along that
border every single year that's why they
are starting to pick up ukrainians
and so this idea that russian or russian
agents or working inside mexico or
elsewhere south of the border for any
number of reasons is not uh is not going
to be unique and it's not surprising
because word is out and the number of
known and suspected terrorists that dhs
is picking up over the last 12 to 13
months has also increased to numbers
that we have never seen before as well
so
you know
it's no secret that if you want to get
across into the united states illegally
your best bet is to do it along that
southern border and to embed yourself
into this historic number a flow of
individuals coming across that border
yeah open border we're inviting a lot
more trouble
chad wolfe thank you for joining us this
morning
thank you